congresswoman alexander ocasio-cortez
accusing people of using racist
language for calling the increase of
migrants at the border what it is which
is a surge
anyone who's using the term surge around
you
consciously is trying to invoke a
militaristic frame
this is not a surge these are children
and they are not insurgents and we are
not being
invaded which by the way is a white
supremacist
idea philosophy
our next guest has seen the surge with
his own eyes and says the congresswoman
is wrong
really senior writer for townhall.com
julio rosa
rojas joins us now julio is that white
supremacist language
of the word surge
uh well look brian uh to start things
off i'm no fan of white supremacists and
white supremacists aren't fans of me
because hello i got brown skin over here
but no this is absolutely a surge and
it's not racist
to call it that i mean the numbers that
i saw just
all last week is just absolutely
staggering in the amount of people
that are illegally crossing and turning
themselves over to
border patrol i mean and yes i'm well
aware that there are kids there
again i was there firsthand and seen
them and often they were by themselves
and so
this is a surge and and one of the
things that's kind of disturbing about
it is that
it's been happening a lot sooner than
when the surges typically happen which
is around april and may and so
we're going to see what the
apprehensions numbers are but uh there
are estimates that we're gonna be over
150
000 apprehensions and of course that's
just the number of people who wanted
uh for the most part wanted to be caught
right and we see how close these cots
are together
we see how these uh these people these
these young children are
right now right on top of each other we
know we're in a pandemic we did not have
to
allow unaccompanied minors to stay we
were flying them back
joe biden changed that as president
united states but aoc who is
the spiritual leader of the left has it
did had a different tone in 2019
when things weren't even as bad as they
are now listen
no child should ever be separated
from their parents no child
should ever be taken from their
family no woman should ever be
locked up in a pen when they have done
no harm to another human being
they should be given water they should
be given basic access
to human rights right so she made up the
last half
as if the people were drinking out of
toilet bowls and said they were locked
up they're not locked up
they were put in facilities that were
there for a small number of people but
they were overwhelmed at the time this
is
worse and her tones changed did it
surprise you
no not at all and really congresswoman
is not alone in this but she really is
kind of the prime example
of democrats and some people in the
media claiming that they were you know
they care about these migrants care
about the conditions that they're in
when it was under president trump and
now obviously
uh that their tune has changed because
this is now a democratic administration
and look it's not like she doesn't know
where texas is she was just
in the state uh after right after the
the winter storms
uh that that passed by through and so uh
she knows where the state is and she
knows where these facilities are and yet
and yet she hasn't made
the effort to come down here and like i
said she's not alone in this and there's
the hypocrisy is absolutely astounding
right that's why you give congressman
cuellar a democrat and other democrats
and
democratic mayors say i just want to
solve the problem i really don't want to
score political points she did come out
yesterday and say
uh this is inhumane unacceptable
horrifying conditions of children
cbp custody but it's not cbp's problem
the problem is the policies that send
these kids here
and right now there's over 18 000 are
you going back real quick
i suspect i'll be going back shortly
because this is a crisis and there is a
surge
right and there's no end to it even if
the president chooses to ignore it
julia rojas thanks so much